Vaya, pensé que habría un podio, así que estoy un poco asustado.
(Risas)
Chris me pidió que les contara otra vez cómo es que descubrimos la estructura del ADN.
Y como Uds. saben, sigo sus órdenes y lo haré.
Pero me aburre un poco.
(Risas)
Y, como saben, escribí un libro. Así que diré algo--
--diré un poco sobre, ya saben, cómo se hizo el descubrimiento,
y porqué Francis y yo lo encontramos.
Y luego, espero tener al menos cinco minutos para decirles
lo que me mueve ahora.
Atrás de mi hay una imagen de cuando tenía 17.
Estaba en la Universidad de Chicago, en mi tercer año,
y estaba en mi tercer año porque la Universidad de Chicago
te permite entrar después de dos años de bachillerato.
Entonces --fue divertido escapar del bachillerato.
Porque yo era muy pequeño, y no era bueno en los deportes,
ni nada por el estilo.
Pero debo hablar de mis antecedentes -- mi padre fue, ya saben,
criado para ser Episcopalista y Republicano.
Pero luego de un año de estudios superiores, se volvió Ateo y Demócrata.
(Risas)
Y mi madre era una Irlandesa Católica,
y -- pero no se tomaba la religión muy enserio.
Y cuando tenía 11, ya no iba a la misa del domingo,
me iba pasear y ver aves con mi padre.
Así que a temprana edad escuché de Charles Darwin.
Supongo, ya saben, que él era el gran héroe.
Y, saben, la vida como es ahora se entiende a través de la evolución.
Y en la Universidad de Chicago estaba estudiando Zoología.
Y pensé que terminaría, ya saben, si era suficientemente brillante,
tal vez obteniendo un Doctorado en ornitología de Cornell.
Luego, en el periódico Chicago, había una reseña de un libro
llamado "¿Qué es la vida?" escrito por el gran físico, Schrodinger.
Y esa, desde luego, ha sido una pregunta que quería conocer.
Saben, Darwin explicó la vida después de que fue iniciada,
pero ¿cuál era la escencia de la vida?
Y Schrodinger dijo que esta escencia era información
presente en nuestros cromosomas, y que tenía que estar presente
en una molécula. Yo nunca había pensado realmente en moléculas anteriormente.
Ya saben, cromosomas, pero eso era una molécula,
y de alguna forma toda la información estaba probablemente presente
en forma digital. Y ahí estaba la gran pregunta de,
¿cómo se copiaba la información?
Entonces ese era el libro. Y, desde ese momento,
quise ser un genetista --
entender los genes y a través de ellos, entender la vida.
Entonces tuve, ya saben, un héroe a distancia.
No era un jugador de baseball, era Linus Pauling.
Entonces apliqué a Caltech y me rechazaron.
(Risas)
Así que fui a Indiana,
que era, de hecho, tan buena como Caltech en genética,
y además, tenían un muy buen equipo de basketball.
Asi que tuve una vida bastante feliz en Indiana.
Y fue en Indiana donde tuve la impresión
de que, ya saben, que el gen era posiblemente ADN.
Y entonces, cuando obtuviera mi Doctorado, debería investigar el ADN.
Entonces primero fui a Copenague porque pensé, bueno,
tal vez me podría volver un bioquímico.
Pero descubrí que la bioquímica era muy aburrida.
No apuntaba hacia, ya saben, decir qué era el gen.
Sólo era ciencia del núcleo. Y ah, ese es el libro, un pequeño libro.
Lo pueden leer como en dos horas.
Y -- entonces me fui a un encuentro en Italia.
Y había un orador inesperado que no estaba en el programa,
y él habló sobre ADN.
Era Maurice Wilkins. Estudió física,
y después de la guerra quiso dedicarse a la biofísica, y escogió el ADN
porque el ADN había sido propuesto en el Rockefeller Institute
a ser posiblemente la molécula genética en los cromosomas.
La mayoría de las personas creían que eran las proteínas.
Pero Wilkins, saben, pensó que el ADN era la mejor opción,
y mostró esta fotografía de rayos-x.
Aparentemente cristalina. Así que el ADN tenía la estructura,
a pesar de que probablemente se lo debía a diferentes moléculas
que llevaran distintos grupos de instrucciones.
Así que había algo universal en la molécula de ADN.
Entonces quería trabajar con él, pero él no quería un ex-observador-de-aves,
y terminé en Cambridge, Inglaterra.
Así que fui a Cambridge,
porque era realmente el mejor lugar del mundo en ese entonces
para cristalografía de rayos-x. Y ahora eso es ahora una materia en
ya saben, los departamentos de química.
O sea, en esos días era terreno de la física.
Así que el mejor lugar para cristalografía de rayos-x
era el Laboratorio Cavendish en Cambridge.
Y ahí conocí a Francis Crick.
Fui ahí sin conocerlo. Él tenía 35, yo 23.
Y en un día, habíamos decidido que
tal vez podríamos tomar un atajo para encontrar la estructura del ADN.
No resolverlo, saben, de la forma tradicional y rigurosa, sino construyendo un modelo.
Un electro-modelo, usando algunas coordenadas de, ya saben,
longitud, y ese tipo de cosas de las fotografías de rayos-x.
Pero tan solo preguntar si la molécula -- ¿cómo se doblaría?
Y la razón para hacerlo, al centro de esta fotografía,
es Linus Pauling. Quien como seis meses antes, propuso
la estructura alfa-hélice para las proteínas. Y al hacerlo,
desterró al hombre a la derecha,
Sir Lawrence Bragg, quien era el profesor del Cavendish.
Esta es una fotografía varios años después,
cuando Bragg tenía razón para sonreir.
Realmente no estaba sonriendo cuando llegué ahí,
porque de alguna forma había sido humillado porque Pauling consiguió la alfa-hélice,
y las personas de Cambridge fallaron porque no eran químicos.
Y ciertamente, ni Crick ni yo eramos químicos,
así que tratamos de construir un modelo. Francis conocía a Wilkins.
Así que Wilkins dijo que pensaba que era la hélice.
el diagrama de rayos-X, él pensó que era compatible con la hélice.
Así que construimos un modelo de tres cadenas.
Vinieron los de Londres.
Wilkins y su colaboradora, o posible colaboradora,
Rosalind Franklin, vinieron y como que se rieron de nuestro modelo.
Dijeron que era malísimo, y lo era.
Así que no hiciéramos más modelos; que eramos incompetentes.
(Risas)
Así que no construimos más modelos,
y Francis como que continuó trabajando en proteínas.
Y básiamente, yo no hice nada. Y --excepto leer.
Ya saben, básicamente, leer es algo bueno; obtienes datos.
Y continuamos diciéndole a las personas en Londres
que Linus Pauling se cambiaría al ADN.
si el ADN era tan importante, Linus lo sabría.
Él construiría un modelo, y nos quitarían la primicia.
Y, de hecho, él le había escrito a las personas en Londres:
si podría él ver su fotografía de rayos-X
Y ellos fueron sabios al decirle "no." Así que no la obtuvo.
Pero había unas en la literatura.
De hecho, Linus no las observó cuidadosamente.
Pero como, eh, 15 meses después de que llegué a Cambridge,
un rumor empezó a surgir del hijo de Linus Pauling,
quien estaba en Cambridge, decía que su padre estaba ahora trabajando con ADN.
Y entonces, un día Peter vino y dijo que él era Peter Pauling,
y me dio una copia del manuscrito de su padre.
Y cielos, estaba asustado porque pensé, saben, nos podrían quitar la primicia.
No tenía nada que hacer, no estaba calificado para nada.
(Risas)
Y entonces ahí estaba el artículo, y él proponía una estructura de tres hebras.
Lo leí y era pura -- era una basura.
(Risas)
Entonces eso era, ya saben, inesperado desde --
-- y entonces, se mantenía unido por puentes de hidrógeno
entre grupos fosfato.
Bueno, si el pH más alto de las células es cerca de siete,
esos puentes de hidrógeno no podrían existir.
Corrimos al departamento de química y dijimos,
"¿Podría estar bien Pauling?" Y Alex Hust dijo, "No." Así que nos pusimos felices.
(Risas)Y
Y, saben, seguíamos en el juego, pero estábamos preocupados
de que alguien en Caltech le dijera a Linus que estaba mal.
Y entonces Bragg nos dijo, "Hagan modelos."
Y un mes después de conseguir el manuscrito de Pauling --
Debo decir que llevé el manuscrito a Londres, y se los enseñé.
Bueno, les dije que Linus estaba equivocado y que seguíamos en el juego
y que debían comenzar inmediatamente a hacer modelos.
Pero Wilkins dijo que no, Rosalin Franklin se iba en dos meses,
y una vez que se fuera entonces él empezaría a hacer modelos.
Entonces volví a Cambridge con esas noticias,
y Bragg dijo, "Hagan modelos."
Bueno, desde luego, yo quería hacer modelos.
Y aquí hay una imagen de Rosalind. Ella realmente, saben,
de cierta forma era una química,
pero en realidad ella habría sido capacitada --
ella no sabía química orgánica o química cuántica.
Era una cristalógrafa.
Y creo que parte de la razón por la que no quería construir modelos
era que no era una química, mientras que Pauling sí lo era.
Entonces Crick y Yo, saben, empezamos a hacer modelos,
y aprendí un poco de química, pero no suficiente.
Bueno, obtuvimos la respuesta el 28 de Febrero de 1953.
Y fue por una regla, que para mi, es una muy buena regla:
Nunca seas la persona más brillante en un cuarto, y no lo éramos.
No éramos los mejores químicos en el cuarto.
Fui y les enseñé un apareamiento que había hecho,
y Jerry Donohue -- él era químico -- dijo, está mal.
Tienes -- los átomos de hidrógeno están en el lugar equivocado.
Yo sólo los puse como estaban en los libros.
Él dijo que estaban mal.
Así que al día siguiente, saben, después de que pensé, "Bueno, él podría estar en lo cierto."
Cambié las ubicaciones, y entonces encontramos el apareamiento de bases,
y Francis inmediatamente dijo que la cadena corre en direcciones absolutas.
Y sabíamos que estábamos en lo correcto.
Así que yo estaba muy, ya saben, esto ocurrió como en dos horas.
De la nada a algo.
Y sabíamos que era algo grande porque, saben, si sólo pones A junto a T
y G junto a C, tienes un mecanismo de copiado.
Así que vimos cómo es que se pasa la información genética.
Es el orden de cuatro bases.
Así que de cierta forma, es un tipo de información digital.
Y lo copias al separar las cadenas.
Así que, saben, si no funcionaba así, podrían al menos creerlo,
porque no había otro esquema.
(Risas)
Pero esa no es la forma en que piensa la mayoría de los científicos.
La mayoría son en realidad aburridos.
Dicen que no pensarán al respecto hasta que nosotros sepamos que está bien.
Pero, saben, pensamos que estábamos al menos 95 o 99 por ciento bien.
Así que piénsenlo. Los siguientes cinco años,
había algo como cinco referencias
a nuestro trabajo en Nature -- ninguna.
Entonces estábamos solos,
intentando armar la tercia: ¿cómo es que --
¿qué es lo que esta información genética hace?
Era bastante obvio que aportaba la información
para una molécula de ARN, y luego ¿cómo vas de ARN a proteína?
Como por tres años nosotros sólo -- Intenté resolver la estructura del ARN.
No rindió frutos. No daba buenas fotografías de rayos-X
Era infeliz; una chica no quiso casarse conmigo.
Era, saben, un tiempecito de mierda.
(Risas)
Aquí hay una imagen de Francis y Yo antes de que conociera a esta chica,
todavía me veo feliz.
(Risas)
Pero hay algo que hicimos cuando no sabíamos
hacia dónde avanzar: formamos el club llamado RNA Tie Club [el Club de corbata ARN]
George Gamow, otro gran físico, diseñó la corbata.
Él era uno de los miembros. La pregunta era:
¿Cómo llegas de un código de cuatro letras
al código de 20 letras para las proteínas?
Feynman era miembro, y Teller, y amigos de Gamow.
Pero esa es la única -- no, nos fotografiaron sólo dos veces.
Y en ambas ocasiones, saben, uno de nosotros no tenía la corbata.
Ahí está Francis arriba a la derecha,
y Álex rich -- el médico-convertido-en-cristalógrafo -- junto a mi.
Esta se tomó en Cambridge en Septiembre de 1955.
Y estoy sonriendo, obligadamente, supongo,
porque la chica que tenía, cielos, se había ido.
(Risas)
Así que no fui realmente feliz sino hasta 1960,
porque entonces encontramos, saben,
que hay tres formas de ARN.
Y sabíamos, básicamente, que el ADN provee la información para el ARN.
el ARN provee la información para la proteína.
Y eso le permitió a Marshall Nirenberg, saben, tomar el ARN -- ARN sintético --
ponerlo en un sistema haciendo proteína. Hizo polifenilalanina,
Así que así se descubrió el código genético por primera vez,
y todo terminó en 1966.
Y así fue, es lo que Chris quería que hiciera, fue --
entonces ¿qué pasó desde entonces?
Bueno, a ese tiempo debo volver.
Cuando encontramos la estructura del ADN, di mi primera charla
en Cold Spring Harbor. El físico, Leo Szilard,
me vió y dijo, "¿Vas a patentar esto?"
Y -- pero él sabía leyes de patentes, y que no podíamos patentarlo,
porque no podías. Era inútil.
(Risas)
Entonces el ADN no se volvió una molécula útil,
y los abogados no entraron en la ecuación sino hasta 1973,
20 años después, cuando Boyer y Cohen en San Francisco
y Stanford dieron con su método de ADN recombinante,
y Stanford lo patentó e hizo mucho dinero.
Al menos ellos patentaron algo
que, saben, podía hacer cosas útiles.
Y entonces, aprendieron cómo leer las letras del código.
Y ¡pum!, teníamos, saben, teníamos la industria biotecnológica. Y,
pero todavía teníamos un largo camino para, saben,
Contestar la pregunta que de cierta forma marcó mi infancia,
que es: ¿Cómo adquieres lo innato?
Y entonces seguiré. Ya se me acabó el tiempo,
pero este es Michael Wigler, un matemático muy muy listo
que se volvió físico. Y él desarrolló una técnica
que escencialmente nos permite observar una muestra de ADN
y, eventualmente, un millón de puntos en ésta.
Ahí hay un chip, uno convencional. Luego hay uno
hecho por una fotolitografía por una compañía en Madison
llamada NimbleGen, que está más avanzada que Affymetrix.
Y usamos su técnica.
Y lo que puedes hacer es comparar ADN normal.
Ahí hay cáncer, y puedes ver en la parte alta
que los cánceres que son malos muestran inserciones o deleciones.
Así que el ADN está realmente arruinado,
mientras que si tienes oportunidad de sobrevivir,
el ADN no está tan arruinado.
Entonces pensamos que eso eventualmente conduciría a lo que llamamos
"biopsia de ADN." Antes de recibir tratamiento para el cáncer,
realmente deberían mantenerse atentos a esta técnica,
y tener una idea de la cara del enemigo.
No es -- es sólo una mirada parcial, pero es un --
creo que será muy muy útil.
Entonces, empezamos con cáncer de mama
porque hay mucho financiamiento para ello, no es dinero del gobierno.
Y ahora tengo cierto interés adquirido:
Lo quiero hacer para el cáncer de próstata. Así que, ya saben,
no recibes tratamiento para esto si no es peligroso.
Pero Wigler, además de ver las células cancerígenas, vió células normales,
e hizo una observación algo sorpresiva.
Que todos tenemos como 10 lugares en nuestro genoma
donde hemos perdido un gen o adquirido otro.
Entonces todos somos como imperfectos. Y la pregunta es,
si estamos aquí, saben,
estas pequeñas pérdidas o ganancias no son tan malas.
Pero si estas deleciones o amplificaciones ocurrieran en el gen equivocado,
tal vez nos sentiríamos mal.
Así que la primera enfermedad que observó fue el autismo.
Y la razón por la que observamos el autismo es porque teníamos el dinero para hacerlo.
Observar a un individuo cuesta como 3,000 dólares. Y el padre de un niño
con la enfermedad de Asperger, el autismo de alta-inteligencia,
envió su análisis a una compañía convencional; no lo aceptaron.
No lo podían hacer por genética convencional, pero sólo explorándolo
empezamos a encontrar genes para el autismo.
Y como pueden ver aquí, hay muchos de ellos.
Entonces, muchos de los niños autistas lo son
porque perdieron una porción grande de ADN.
Quiero decir, grande a nivel molecular.
Vimos un niño autista,
que no tenía como cinco millones de bases en uno de sus cromosomas.
Todavía no hemos observado a los padres, pero probablemente
no tengan esa pérdida, o no podrían ser padres.
Ahora, nuestro estudio del autismo acaba de empezar. Conseguimos 3 millones de dólares.
Creo que costará al menos 10 a 20 antes de que podamos
ayudar a los padres que han tenido un niño autista,
o que creen que podrían tener un hijo autista,
y ¿podemos notar la diferencia?
Entonces esta misma técnica debería verlos todos.
Es una forma maravillosa de encontrar genes.
Y entonces, concluiré diciendo
que hemos visto a 20 personas con esquizofrenia.
Y pensamos que tendríamos que ver probablemente a varios cientos
antes de ver todo el problema. Pero como pueden ver,
hay siete de 20 que tuvieron un cambio muy grande.
Y aún así, en los controles había tres.
Entonces, ¿cuál es el significado de los controles?
¿Estaban locos también y no lo notamos?
O, saben, ¿eran normales? Yo supongo que son normales.
Y lo que pensamos es que son genes que predisponen a la esquizofrenia,
y ya sea que predisponga --
y luego hay sólo un sub-segmento de la población
que es capaz de ser esquizofrénico.
Realmente no tenemos evidencia de esto,
pero creo que, para darles una hipótesis, que la mejor suposición
es que si eres zurdo, eres vulnerable a la esquizofrenia.
30% de los esquizofrénicos son zurdos,
y la esquizofrenia tiene una genética muy peculiar,
Lo que significa que 60% de las personas son genéticamente zurdas,
pero sólo la mitad de ellos lo muestran. No tengo tiempo para decirlo.
Algunas personas que creen ser diestras
son genéticamente zurdas. Sólo estoy diciendo que, si piensas,
oh, yo no tengo gen zurdo, entonces mi, ya saben,
hijos no tienen riesgo de tener esquizofrenia. Deberían reconsiderarlo. ¿OK?
(Risas)
Entonces, para mi, estos son tiempos extraordinariamente emocionantes.
Debemos ser capaces de encontrar el gen para el trastorno bipolar;
hay una relación.
Y si consigo suficiente dinero, lo habremos encontrado todos este año.
Gracias.